die grundstücke in volkswagen in
mecklenburg vorpommern sind seit mehr
als einem jahrzehnt an die zentrale
kanalisation angeschlossen ihren
abwasseranschluss haben die menschen
teuer bezahlt aber jetzt nach zehn
jahren werden sie noch mal zur kasse
gebeten
einige sollen sogar fast 20.000 euro
nachzahlen die menschen hier im dorf
sind stinksauer
natürlich haben wir alle erwartet wir
sind mit durch wir haben vor zehn jahren
bezahlt und jetzt sollen wir noch mal
zahlen warum wieso also ich bin rentner
ich habe die post rente ist nicht sehr
hoch ich weiß nicht wo das geld
hernehmen soll
mir geht es beschissen dabei abzocke
abzocke vom feinsten die haben jetzt
festgestellt alles klar
da lässt sie noch geld raus sauber die
pressen wir aus ich finde richtig
verarscht der ärger beginnt in den 90er
jahren weil kein abwassernetz gebaut
wird muss sich jedes haus für einige
1000 d-mark eine bio kläranlage in den
garten setzen 2007 werden doch rohre
verlegt alle grundstücke kommen ans
abwassernetz torsten harms zahl damals
knapp 3700 euro für seinen anschluss
einmalig wie es hieß aber ein paar jahre
später stellte abwasserzweckverband
mahlow bad sülze plötzlich fest die
eigene satzung ist ungültig und bei den
bescheiden hat man sich leider
verrechnet daraufhin erlässt der
kommunale verband eine neue satzung und
verschickt neue bescheide mit teils
heftigen folgen herr harms etwa muss
nochmal fast 19.000 euro zahlen
ich bin früher mit 900 euro rente
19.000 euro hinblättern so otto
portokasse dort schon eine nummer für
den verbandsvorsteher des
abwasserzweckverbandes ist das nach
erhebende beiträge alternativlos auch
wenn er den ärger der menschen verstehen
kann sicherlich das ein vertrauensbruch
aber der gesetzgeber schreibt vor dass
wenn wir wissen dass nicht alle flächen
erhoben wurden die dazu verpflichtet
sind diese flächen auch anzufassen und
zu bescheiden ansonsten verstehen
verstoßen gegen geltendes recht
den bürgerinnen und bürgern hilft das
nicht sie halten das ganze für pure
geldmacherei
ich will mich mein tisch gezogen und
dich für ernst genommen ist zieht
familien erst mal runter sie haben
anderes geplant und sie wissen nicht wie
sie das bewerkstelligen
die betroffenen in volkswagen haben eine
bürgerinitiative gegründet und wollen
jetzt gemeinsam gegen die
abwasseranschluss bescheide kämpfen